Malcolm Perry joining us after the great
performance over the weekend as Navy
roughs up army and he became the fourth
quarterback in FBS history to rush for
at least 300 yards in a game and he
joins us now
Malcolm congratulations what is Monday
like after the win against arming um
pretty sore from the most part you know
we still got exams and stuff going on so
everybody's pretty focused but like in
this waking up this morning was a lot
easier than it usually is but what do
you what is the Academy again what are
the mid mid ship and get because you
beat for me um we find out here soon
after the game that Don told us that we
have some coming our way so we're still
looking looking forward to what that is
and we'll see what do you want it to be
um some form of missing school that
would be nice I have no idea what was
the pregame speech the locker room like
um just like any other game you know we
tried to keep it as normal as possible
just uh trying to let coach me am I
trying to let everybody know you know we
got this we practice all week we deserve
it you know you go out go out there and
earn it so yeah but it's not another
game and you know that and everybody
else knows that right it's not it's not
at all you know you can tell that once
you walk out the tunnel
you know there's however many fans it
feels like a million staring down at you
you know lights camera action everything
all the stuff that comes with it and
that's something that goes near my
focused on early on and we can practice
just trying to make us feel comfortable
with with what's all gonna be going on
during the game so for the most part
going into the game I feel like the team
was pretty comfortable not letting all
the distractions get to us so we tried
to keep it as normal as possible how
nervous were you um extremely nervous
probably probably the most nervous I've
ever been for a game seen as though it
was our senior year last last chance to
beat on me yeah I was I was extremely
nervous tried to hide as much as
possible from the team and everybody but
I was pretty nervous
is there smack talk between the service
academies during the game Oh every play
I try to I try to keep out of it
but yeah literally every place well what
did they say to you you may not respond
but what are they saying to you I don't
know what army could be saying to you
after that elements a couple of things I
don't know if I could say but you know
it's just football um you know nothing
that is it out of character for any any
any football team but definitely more
than usual explain this to me and the
audience back in 2016 you made your
debut in a game that I don't believe you
dressed for was that the game against
Fordham where you're in the stands
cheering you had played junior varsity
that week right so yeah so what happens
um so right on that Friday I played in
the JV game with the rest of the guys
that weren't traveling or addressing for
the for the first game of the season
that year and so was my freshman year
traveled over to the game with the rest
of the team got to eat at the tailgate
for the game was sitting in the stands
eating Twizzlers while the team was
warming up and we got to watching the
game saw that um toggle unfortunately
went down with an injury will worst went
in the score got pretty jacked up so you
know I kind of figured that somebody
else is going in and then eventually I
saw one of the managers running up in
the stands like screaming screaming my
name I was like what did you want what
did you want so it takes me take him
down to the locker room through the
tunnel and stuff like that and I'm I'm
still confused at that point what's
going on but I get in the locker room
and they tell me they're gonna dress me
out and let me stand on the sidelines
and uh so I go out there and still
really don't don't expect to get in the
game and play but I was just I was just
excited to be down there but eventually
I got I got the call to go in and I got
to run around a little bit and uh
experience my first taste of college
football so it was a great experience
did you get to stretch what is that oh
yeah yeah of course
okay I get this edge all right but you
didn't want to play the position a
quarterback when you when you first got
to the Naval Academy did you um I
wouldn't I would I didn't want to I just
had an option that I'd rather play I'd
rather play slab
and they gave me the option coming in
which one I wanted to play but
eventually it got around to me coming
back to playing quarterback which you
know I wasn't the most excited about but
I didn't hate it so eventually it got to
the point where I'd rather play
quarterback over anything so I'm happy
about that I knew you grew up in
Tennessee how disappointed that the
volunteers didn't recruit you Oh
extremely
that was like that's like my dream
school growing up they could use your
Malcolm I wish I wish they would have
but you know I'm happy where I'm at now
and it's good I when you told your
parents that you were going to Navy
they'd served in in the army I believe
for mm-hmm
what for housing what was that
conversation like when you say to mom
and dad hey I know that your army I'm
going to Navy it was it was received a
little bit better than I thought it
would be my mom was fully on board my
dad likes to you know flip-flop between
who is room for depending on what day of
the year it is so I gotta watch him
every once in awhile but other than that
it was it was pretty it was pretty
smooth they pretty much left it all up
to me and where I felt most comfortable
at so I'm thankful for them sorry are
you a big deal on campus I wouldn't say
so
like teachers do they like professors
you know autograph like hey I'm just
curious what it's like for you you know
with a performance like that and walking
on campus yeah not much has changed a
lot more people saying hi hello
a couple autographs here and there yeah
but for the most part I think they do a
good job of treating me just like
anybody you know we're talking to
Malcolm Perry the Navy quarterback
I put your third on my Heisman ballot I
don't know if anybody told you but I put
Joe borough number one chase young
number two and you number three and I
had to turn in my ballot before your
performance so thanks you made me look a
lot better that you know you had that
great performance but you know trying to
get any kind of like do you hope that
you expect to get any NFL offers
somebody curious about bringing you into
play um I feel like you know the
opportunity presents itself then I'm all
for it
you know like any other player
I grew up playing football that's
something that they looked they looked
up to and they they wanted to pursue so
I would be extremely grateful for the
opportunity for sure but you got a
favorite team are the Titans of course
oh okay
if you're the Commandant comes in do you
have to hang up if somebody comes in
right now you have to um yeah yeah call
the pitcher on deck stand at attention
you get in trouble um have you gotten
into trouble no not not I'm pretty good
at staying out of trouble
what about you know doing push like how
do they do stuff where you first got
there - do you get roughed up yeah plebe
summer it's pretty rough that's when
they kind of break you down and
introduce you to the military life
that's when everybody gets in trouble
there you really have no idea what's
going on everybody screaming at you
you're doing push-ups you're running
around in circles you kind of have no
idea what's going on but now that I'm a
senior now that I kind of see you know
what they put us through and why they
put us through that I'm pretty I'm
pretty good at staying out of trouble
doing I'm supposed to do and and making
sure others are doing the same and
running the football yeah yeah a little
bit quantitative economics is your major
yes sir you're kind of showing off a
little bit aren't you not at all yes
what are you gonna do with that I'm not
sure um I just knew I was interested in
business and money and that was one of
the biggest things for me it's just
majoring in something that I was
interested in and possibly going to use
in the future so well congrats it was a
lot of fun to watch you and if the
Commandant comes in you tell him you
give him the phone and then I'll take
over from there and say no now you stand
down you stand down I'm not sure that
I'm gonna end up doing push-ups but
congratulations that was a wonderful
performance you got Kansas State coming
up in the AutoZone Liberty Bowl that'll
be at the end of the year December 31st
on ESPN Thank You Malcolm and thanks for
a great performance thanks for having me
I appreciate it and that's uh Malcolm
Perry good kid there for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]